hardly anything runs in our society
today without microchips
they are the heart of cell phones
computers cars a chip is made up of
transistors tiny switches 10 000 times
smaller than a human hair that control
the flow of electrons through a circuit
billions of transistors are packed into
an area smaller than a fingernail
microchips are one of humankind's most
remarkable achievements and it wouldn't
be possible to make the world's most
sophisticated ships without the German
company Zeiss
in a previous video I talked about how
the Dutch firm asml is the only company
in the world that builds the machines
that create the circuitry for the most
advanced chips these machines wouldn't
be able to operate without Zeiss mirrors
inside of them these are not your
average mirrors they're a complex
Optical system that miniaturizes the
structure of a chip printed on a silicon
wafer light is projected through a
blueprint of the pattern that will be
printed Zeiss Optics Focus the pattern
onto the wafer which has already been
coated with a light sensitive chemical
it shrinks the pattern down to the
nanometer level a nanometer is one
billionth of a meter in the end the
wafer is cut into small pieces of
microchips
while asml's less Advanced chip making
machines use lenses to focus light
lenses won't work for its most advanced
lithography machines because these
machines use extreme ultraviolet light
which lenses would absorb euv is a
shorter wavelength of light than that
used by conventional chip making
machines euv light can help pack more
transistors onto a chip making the chip
more powerful
since Zeiss cannot use lenses for the
most advanced machines it uses mirrors a
series of ultra reflective curved
mirrors guide the light in a vacuum
chamber the mirrors need to be extremely
flat because even the smallest
irregularity leads to Imaging errors
we're not talking about your typical
level of smoothness
they are hyper smooth polished to a
thickness of less than one atom what
does that even mean
well if you were to enlarge the mirror
to the size of Germany then the tallest
mountain would be less than one
millimeter high
Zeiss makes the flattest mirrors on
Earth they are held in a position as
precisely as possible during the
exposure process
they are so stable that if a zeissmir
were to redirect a laser beam and aim it
at the Moon it would be able to hit a
ping pong ball on its surface
asml knows how crucial Zeiss is to its
entire operation it's no wonder that in
2016 asml bought a billion Euro stake in
a subsidiary of Zeiss purchasing 25 of
the shares of Carl Zeiss smt Zeiss and
asml pretty much have no Rivals every
one of the most advanced chips on Earth
has passed through their system they
Supply Taiwan semiconductor
manufacturing company which produces
over 90 percent of the world's most
advanced chips tsmc makes five nanometer
chips and is striving to make even
smaller three nanometer ones
the Strategic partnership between Zeiss
and asml means the barrier to entry for
potential competitors is exceedingly
High other manufacturers could try to
build their own euv lithography machines
however if China does want to build a
machine that could rival Zeiss and asmls
analysts believe it would take at least
10 years for them to do so trouble is
China cannot access the most advanced
equipment from Zeiss and asml right now
because the Trump Administration pressed
asml hard to block sales of its most
advanced euv lithography machines to
China and the Biden Administration has
brought in chip restrictions against
Beijing which I discussed in a previous
video that I'll link in my description
since Zeiss was founded by German
entrepreneur Carl Zeiss in the mid-1800s
it has grown to secure the advantage in
Optics on the world stage
yet it's not sitting comfortably Zeiss
is already working on Next Generation
Optics by increasing the numerical
aperture the numerical aperture is a
measure of how much light the optical
system can collect and focus the
increase in the numerical aperture will
significantly improve the resolution
improving the resolution will increase
the number of transistors that can be
packed onto the chip making it even more
powerful
and as her future moves toward
autonomous driving artificial
intelligence and 5G and Beyond you can
bet there will be a demand forever more
powerful processors in the machines that
make them
building the world's most powerful
lenses and mirrors would not be possible
without talented Engineers if you'd like
to improve your math science and
computer science skills to help build
the future or simply for your own
personal pleasure brilliant is a great
way to brush up on your stem skills I
know my viewers especially love their
scientific thinking course where you can
explore the center of mass interactively
or make a bridge as rigid as possible
with as few beams as possible another
course that my viewers enjoy is computer
science fundamentals where you can build
algorithms and navigate drones to their
proper destination I personally love
their logic courses in this exercise I'm
working on you have to put things in the
correct order
if you ever get stuck you can view the
explanation for more brilliant is great
whether you're a student or you're a
professional already in the workplace
and it's free for you to try out with my
custom link in the description
brilliant.org newsthink that's
brilliant.org newsthink the first 200
people to sign up with my custom link
will get 20 off brilliant's annual
premium subscription which gives you
access to all of their course offerings
including their most advanced courses
thanks for watching for a news think I'm
Cindy Palm